>>> THIS IS A FASCINATING PIECE
OF REPORTING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
TALKBOUT NOW.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH THIS
PHOTO FROM SEPTEMBER 9, 1957
SHOWING DALLAS COWBOYS OWNER
JERRY JONES AMID A CROWD OF
WHITE STUDENTS TRYING TO KEEP
BLACK STUDENTS FROM INTEGRATING
AT A ARKANSAS HIGH SCHOOL.
REPORT THAT JONES WHO WAS 14 AT
THE TIME COULD BE SEEN STANDING
A FEW YARDS FROM WHERE THE SIX
BLACK STUDENTS WERE JOSTLED AND
REPELLED WITH RACIAL SLURS BY
RING LEADERS OF THE MOB.
SO WITH US SALLY JENKINS, WHO
BROKE THIS STORY WITH HER
CO-AUTHOR DAVID MORAN NIS.
WE'RE HAPPY YOU COULD JOIN US
THIS MORNING.
THIS WHOLE THING IS --
>> IT'S STUNNING.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE PICTURE
AND SEE HOW HE COULD MOVE
DIVERSITY ALONG WITH COACHING
AND THE SPORT.
WHAT DID YOU LEARN FROM THIS
PHOTOGRAPH?
>> WELL, I THINK THE FIRST THING
YOU LEARN IS JUST HOW WIDESPREAD
THE SEGREGATIONISTS WERE IN
LITTLE ROCK AND NORTH LITTLE
ROCK.
JERRY JONES' HIGH SCHOOL WAS
NORTH LITTLE ROCK WHICH WAS
ACROSS THE ARKANSAS RIVER FROM
CENTRAL HIGH SCHOOL, WHICH WAS
THE SCHOOL THAT GOT ALL THE
ATTENTION WHEN EISENHOWER SENT
IN TROOPS TO PROTECT THE LITTLE
ROCK NINE.
BUT THE AGITATORS WERE ACTIVE ON
BOTH SITES AND THE FACT THAT WE
KNEW THAT GENERATIONALLY JERRY
JONES HAD TO HAVE EXPERIENCED
THE EVENTS IN LITTLE ROCK MORE
GENERALLY BUT TO FIND HIM IN THE
ALP
PHOTOGRAPH AND LEARN THAT HE
EXPERIENCED ONE OF THOSE
INCIDENTS ON THE STEPS WAS
PRETTY REVELATORY.
>> LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THIS
PICTURE.
HE WAS SAYING I WAS JUST THERE,
I WASN'T PARTICIPATING, I WAS
THERE TO OBSERVE.
BUT THE -- WITH THE PHOTOGRAPH
WHICH YOU POINT OUT IN YOUR
REPORTING IN ORDER TO GET WHERE
HE WAS AT THE TOP OF THE STAIRS
HE HAD TO GET UP QUICKLY AND
THOSE WERE THE STUDENTS KEEPING
THE BLACK STUDENTS FROM
ENTERING.
DOES THIS SAY ANYTHING ABOUT HIS
PARTICIPATION?
ARE YOU MAKING ANY SORT OF
JUDGMENT ABOUT IT?
>> WELL, TWO THINGS.
FIRST OF ALL -- SO HE'S ACTUALLY
YOUNGER THAN THE RING LEADERS
YOU CAN SEE IN THE PHOTOGRAPHS.
THAT'S ONE THING WE NOTICED.
WE LOOKED AT A SEQUENCE OF
PHOTOS LEADING UP TO THOSE STEPS
AND THE WHITE TEENAGERS ON THE
STEPS DID HAVE TO MOVE AROUND
THE BLACK STUDENTS TO GET TO THE
TOP OF THE STEPS.
NEVERTHELESS, HE IS FURTHER
BACK, HE IS YOUNGER THAN THE
LEAD PARTICIPANTS.
SO I THINK THAT YOU SIMPLY HAVE
TO TAKE HIM AT HIS WORD UNLESS
SOMETHING ELSE APPEARS THAT HE
WAS THERE MORE OUT OF CURIOSITY
AND FASCINATION AS OPPOSED TO
BEING AT THE EPICENTER OF THE
ACTIVE EVENTS.
ONE THING HE TOLD US THAT HE DID
NOT MAKE IT IN THE STORY IS HE
REMEMBERS IT GOT PHYSICAL.
THE TOUGH GUYS YOU SEE IN THE
CENTER OF THE PHOTOGRAPH END UP
REALLY PUSHING THE KIDS DOWN OFF
THE STEPS.
AND, IN FACT, ONE OF THEM IS
ARRESTED.
>> I HOPE EVERYONE TAKES A
MOMENT TO READ THE REPORTING
THAT YOU AND DAVID DID AS THEY
WATCH FOOTBALL.
THE REASON YOU DID THIS IS NOT
JUST ABOUT THAT PHOTO.
IT'S ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS WITH
HIS POSITION OF POWER IN THE
LEAGUE NOW AND THE NFL NOW, AND
THE POSITION AND POWER THE
COWBOYS HAVE.
THIS IS PART OF WHAT "THE
WASHINGTON POST" IS DOING,
EXAMINING THE NFL'S DECADES LONG
FAILURE TO PROMOTE BLACK
COACHES, RIGHT?
>> YES.
>> AND I -- GO AHEAD.
>> THIS STORY IS PART OF A LONG
SERIES WE'VE BEEN DOING CALLED
BLACKOUT, WHICH IS EXAMINING THE
ISSUES IN THE LEAGUE ABOUT THE
FACT THAT ALMOST 70% OF THE
WORKFORCE IS BLACK AND YET THERE
ARE ONLY THREE HEAD COACHES.
ONE OF THE THINGS OUR DATA HAS
FOUND IS THAT MID LEVEL -- BLACK
COACHES WHO DO MANAGE TO GET
HEAD COACHING JOBS WAITED AN
AVERAGE OF NINE YEARS LONGER IN
MID LEVEL ASSISTANCE COACHING
PARTS THAN THEIR WHITE COUNTER
PARTS SO THERE'S STRIKING
INEQUITIES WITHIN THE LEAGUE AS
THE LEAGUE ADMITS.
JERRY JONES WAS THE ONLY OWNER
TO TALK TO US IN THIS SERIES IN
ANY WAY.
WE GIVE HIM CREDIT FOR SITTING
DOWN AND HAVING THIS DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION.
>> I'M GLAD YOU BRING IT UP.
THEY ALL SHOULD HAVE TALKED TO
YOU BY THE WAY.
ONE OF THE WELL KNOWN RETIRED
SPORTS CASTERS IN DALLAS, DALE
HANSON, SAID WHAT FRUSTRATES ME
MOST IS THAT JERRY JONES IS IN
SUCH A POSITION THAT IF HE TAKES
A STRONG CHANCE HE COULD BE THE
CHANGE IN THE LEAGUE.
AND IT SEEMS THAT JERRY JONES
AGREES.
>> HE DID AGREE.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE MORE
INTERESTING THINGS IN OUR
CONVERSATION WITH HIM WHICH
LASTED WELL OVER TWO AND A HALF
HOURS P.
HE SAID, I UNDERSTAND THAT, I
AGREE WITH THAT.
WE DISCUSSED WHY HE HADN'T BEEN
AT THE FOREFRONT OF THIS ISSUE
UNTIL NOW.
AND THE SHORT ANSWER TO THAT IS
THAT HE'S BEEN MORE CONCERNED
WITH TRYING TO WIN, YOU KNOW,
SUPER BOWLS AND APPOINTING MEN
WHO WERE OLD FRIENDS OF HIS OR
WHO HE KNEW TO THE JOB.
HIS SECOND HEAD COACH WAS BARRY
SWITZER, A GUY HE WENT WAY BACK
TO ARKANSAS WITH.
SO HE'S FORTHRIGHT IN TRYING TO
ADDRESS THESE TOUGH QUESTIONS.
IT DOESN'T MEAN YOU'LL ALWAYS BE
SATISFIED BY HIS ANSWERS.
BUT HE WAS ONE OF THE ONLY
OWNERS -- THE ONLY OWNER TO SIT
DOWN AND TALK TO US TO THIS
EXTENT ABOUT IT.
>> YOU HAVE TO GIVE HIM CREDIT.
BUT THERE ARE FAILURES, THERE
ARE FAILURES IN THE NFL AS THIS
IS POINTING OUT.
AS YOU HAVE BEEN REPORTING THIS,
SALLY, IT'S GREAT, EVERYONE
SHOULD READ THIS.
IT'S FASCINATING.
SO WHAT'S THE SOLUTION HERE?
WHAT DO YOU THINK SHOULD BE
DONE?
>> WELL, I THINK ONE SOLUTION IS
THE NFL HAS LAUNCHED AN
INAUGURAL ACCELERATOR PROGRAM.
IT'S NOT A SOLUTION.
IT'S A TOOL.
IT'S A MECHANISM TO TRY TO HELP
OWNERS GET TO KNOW OWNERS MORE
PERSONALLY.
A LOT OF TIMES WHAT THEY LACK
ARE THE CLOSE PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIPS.
THAT'S ONE THING WE'VE HEARD.
OWNERS DON'T SPEND MUCH TIME
WITH THEM.
YOU KNOW, OWNERS TALK TO LOTS OF
HEAD COACHES.
THEY TALK TO VERY FEW ASSISTANT
COACHES.
IF YOU'RE AN OWNER OF THE GIANTS
OR THE COWBOYS YOU'RE NOT
SPENDING A GREAT DEAL OF TIME
TALKING TO YOUR RUNNING BACKS
COACH.
SO THIS ACCELERATOR PROGRAM IS
ONE IDEA TO TRY TO GET THE
RELATIONSHIPS MOVING ALONG.
WE'LL SEE IF IT WORKS.
QUITE FRANKLY, A MUCH BETTER
IDEA IS FOR A TEAM LIKE THE
DALLAS COWBOYS, A MAKER OF
MANORS, TO HIRE A BLACK HEAD
COACH, HAVE A WINNING RECORD AND
WIN A SUPER BOWL WITH ONE.
WHEN TONY DUNGY WAS HIRED AND
WON A SUPER BOWL WITH THE COLTS,
IT LOOKED LIKE IT WAS GOING TO
TRIGGER MOVING FORWARD.
>> SALLY JENKINS JOINS US.
AND DAVID MORANIS IS THE
CO-WRITER JT JERRY JONES HELPED
TRANSFORM THE NFL EXCEPT WEN
WHEN IT COMES TO RACE.
IT'S A FASCINATING READ.
I THINK EVERYONE SHOULD CHECK IT
OUT.
THANK YOU, HAPPY THANKSGIVING TO